the K one timer [Applause] score Nathan M
Kennon the game-winning overtime power play
goal mat your scores it's a game winner and
number 30 for Austin Matthews and the leap
s back to back in Southern California that
release what a player and you can't let this
guy in one-on-one he doesn't miss many times to
Matthews fired scores Austin Matthews stays red
hot oh man and McKinnon's got to breakway to
win it in overtime he scores Nathan M Kennon
Austin Matthews ties it up and then this
release right over the shoulder thank you
very much Nobody Does it Better Than Austin
Matthews seven goals in his last five games
that might be the best hit I've seen Nathan
McKinnon deliv in his career Taps it back
and Sho scores Austin oh man that's not banked
off the shoulder that's just underneath the bar
McKinnon point streak at Hope continues his home
point streak to start the season is run out of
22 games amazing the game centers Matthew shoot
scores and just like that the game is tied to
two